ah the life of a fish so serene so safe
from the many predators on land
absolutely no way a bird could plummet
out of a tree and murder you well never
mind them that was a Kingfisher so named
because it's good at fishing for Kings
or something you'll find that often
brilliantly coloured kingfishers all
over the world their favorite haunts are
rivers and ponds anything aquatic really
typically the bird will post up on a
branch or hover over the water keeping
an eye out for fish below hovering is
all the more impressive considering the
Kingfisher has to keep its head steady
while beating its wings eight times a
second and keep in mind that because of
the way light bends when it hits water
to the bird the fish won't appear where
it actually is but in a flash the
Kingfisher strikes firing into the water
and either snagging or spearing the fish
like a box then it's back to the perch
where the bird bashes the prior to knock
it out cold and swallows it whole but
that means the Kingfisher is getting
into just about junk like foam so when
it's done digesting the good stuff it
costs up the bone as a pellet like an
hour and voila
a sad life cycle of the kingfishers
victim not so uppity anymore now are we